it seems like everything is going green
these days
but there's one mode of transportation
that seems to be clinging to the
traditional fuel-loving ways
and while commercial aviation has made
strides through smarter design and
cleaner engines
many of those gains have been nullified
by
more air traffic
the challenge is enormous this is a
large industry it will take decades to
convert
the good news is that
we will have a solution as early as
three years out that people can get into
and and start moving zero
emissions and it turns out that the
solution could be all around us
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe
and so
if you had to use something
it would be great
the only product of the chemical
reaction between hydrogen oxygen
is water
we looked at the fundamentals of what it
would require to take an aircraft up in
the air of significant size over
significant distance commercially
relevant you get to hydrogen fuel cell
being the best approach from the cost of
fuel efficiency of utilization of the
fuel and the mitigation of the climate
effects
serial cleantech entrepreneur val
miftikov started zero avia following his
previous success in the ev charging
industry
so the beauty about
hydrogen in general is that the energy
density of hydrogen as fuel is is
actually three times better than jet
fuel so you can see
any size of aircraft going for any
distance that jet fuel aircraft can go
over time right it will just take
significant amount of time to get the
industry over but this technology can
scale to all sizes of aircraft that we
use in commercial service
xero avia uses a hydrogen fuel cell to
produce electricity to turn a propeller
unlike a traditional engine which uses
combustion to create energy a fuel cell
generates electricity through an
electrochemical reaction in this case
hydrogen and oxygen are combined to
generate electricity heat and water
zero avia has flown a six-seater
aircraft on a hydrogen fuel cell a world
first
now they're aiming bigger at 20 seats
that's technically commercial
one side of the aircraft the left side
will replace the engine with our power
plants we still got the normal engine on
the right side and part of this is you
know in aviation you want to
ramp up a risk profile on in meaningful
steps so anything happens we have the
second engine
but even in the first
flight test campaign
what we're planning to do is to
demonstrate operation of this aircraft
purely on zero emission power on the
left side engine once we take off we're
able to switch over to completely
zero emission power
hydrogen is used throughout all sections
of a flight that maximizes the
efficiency of the entire operation that
reduces the weight provides for best
sort of mission capabilities payload and
range
building power plants and fuel cells is
one thing
creating a whole new infrastructure for
supplying hydrogen is something entirely
different
in automotive big part of the reason why
hydrogen did not
take off
is because the
fueling infrastructure needs to be so
distributed
[Music]
let's say united states you have hundred
thousand fueling stations compare that
with aviation where 95 or more traffic
in the united states is concentrated in
100 locations right so that's a three
order magnitude difference which makes
build out of the infrastructure much
simpler it's much larger much more
concentrated stations but they're much
fewer
in quantity
calling it simpler
might be underselling the challenge of
distributing hydrogen which unlike other
fuels that can be easily transported in
liquid form is usually found instead in
a gaseous state
how do you get the hydrogen from point a
to point b we don't have pipelines for
moving hydrogen around we don't have all
the specialized trucks to move them
around and so
we got thinking we need a solution that
can be a low capital expenditure
solution and that's the genesis of the
company
john paul clark is the co-founder and
chief innovation officer of universal
hydrogen a startup that has designed a
modular tank system for the domestic
turboprop market
like xero avia it allows for
retrofitting planes already in use
each module has two capsules and so what
we do is load it into the aircraft as if
it was cargo strap it down connect it to
the aircraft close the loading door and
that would be it when you get to your
destination
you'd basically unload it
put it back in a truck
send it back
to the
production site to get refilled we
needed to basically come up with
something that could both fit in
containers and also fit in the aircraft
not require increases in the maximum
takeoff weight of the aircraft
this compromise is one of the biggest
hurdles that may prevent widespread
adoption of hydrogen
obviously you're going to have to take
out some seats because the energy
density of hydrogen is less than jet
fuel and you can't store it in the wings
practically so you're going to have to
take away some space in the fuselage
in the ultrafine margins of aviation
removing 10 to 20 percent of your seats
is a tough ask
but that hasn't deterred startups like
zero avia or universal hydrogen
the maintenance cost of a fuel cell
motor system
goes down and it goes down significantly
because motors
and fuel cells have much fewer moving
parts than a gas turbine engine
and so the wear and tear
is much lower and therefore the time
between overhaul is longer and so when
you put all that together
our numbers indicate that the chasm cost
per available seat mile actually goes
down slightly or is at the worst
equivalent to what you have now so what
you will have
is a smaller
cabin a smaller number of seats however
the cost
for each of those seats to operate it
is the same or better with the hydrogen
like zero avia universal hydrogen is
also working on engines
successfully testing their two megawatt
iron bird that will allow them to
retrofit planes carrying up to 55
passengers
xero avia is aiming for their first
commercial hydrogen electric flight
between london and rotterdam with their
19 seater by around 2024
but much like the range anxiety that has
plagued some battery-powered electric
vehicles on land
hydrogen fuel cells are also fairly
limited
at this point they still don't have the
capacity to power a common 100 passenger
jet
beyond fuel cells however there's
another hope for our lightest most
abundant element
burning
[Music]
the first eureka moment i suppose is
when we saw steam and exhaust because we
were thinking to ourselves huh we're
burning something here when we're
producing absolutely no co2
an expert in gas turbine combustion
professor bobby saty leads research at
cranfield university in the uk
built on a former raf base the college
runs multiple aeronautical programs
but what bobby is focused on is burning
hydrogen as cleanly as possible
so what we're trying to demonstrate in
this rig is how we can conceive some
hydrogen combustion technologies that
can be integrated in the next generation
aircraft engines which will deliver not
only low zero co2 emissions but also
ultralinox emissions
nox or nitrogen oxides are a significant
source of air pollution globally
they're the dirty particulates that
cause smog in cities usually spat out by
diesel cars scooters and buses
hydrogen is characterized by much wider
flammability limits which means we can
go to much leaner combustion and as a
result we can burn at much lower flame
temperatures and that's better for
reducing nox emissions
going leaner means burning fuel with an
excess of air in the engine using
something like gasoline
lean burn emits far fewer hydrocarbons
doing it with hydrogen also delivers
cleaner emissions
while nox is a pollutant hydrogen
combustion produces up to 90 percent
less nitrogen oxide than kerosene
so while burning hydrogen isn't
technically as clean as using it inside
a fuel cell it's still a huge
improvement over jet fuel
unfortunately like any radically new
idea
there are other potential byproducts of
the process that aren't fully yet
understood
knox is clearly one of the main
emissions we need to consider but the
aviation community is also asking
themselves and the community in general
what about all the water vapor emissions
and some studies have shown albeit
there's still a large degree of
uncertainty about it that contrails and
cirrus clouds that may be induced from
contrails could contribute to global
warming about four times the amount than
co2 does
we know that if we're going to be
burning hydrogen we're going to produce
much larger amount of water vapor
emissions and if we are going to be
producing a much larger amount of water
vape emissions then the propensity for
contrail formation is also going to
increase
in spite of all these challenges
hydrogen is being taken seriously by the
broader industry
companies like universal hydrogen and
xero avia are gaining the attention of
investors looking for viable and
eventually profitable solutions
industry giant airbus wants to introduce
a hydrogen-powered passenger aircraft by
2035
recently announcing plans to retrofit a
gas guzzling super jumbo with a hydrogen
burning engine
the modified aircraft will add a fifth
engine adapted for hydrogen and will be
mounted on the rear fuselage
the a380 is the largest passenger
aircraft in existence so it offers
plenty of room to store the 400
kilograms of hydrogen
the company's designs for a blended wing
concept to store extra hydrogen also
offer a glimpse of our flying future
apart from the complex engineering
challenges faced by airplane
manufacturers there are also
difficulties in production of hydrogen
itself
nowadays most of the hydrogen used in
fuel is derived by splitting it off from
molecules of natural gas
but that requires a good deal of energy
and also produces carbon dioxide
to make green hydrogen the electricity
used to run the electrolyzer must come
from a renewable resource which is
currently a lot more expensive
as with any new technology however
initial costs are daunting but time may
be the best remedy here
if you look at economics of hydrogen
fuel production for example versus
fossil fuels for instance the cost of
hydrogen is all based on capital expense
and very little operating expense it's
sort of similar to solar power right you
put solar panels out there and they they
produce power for 20 25 years the
operating expense is relatively low what
that means is that as scale grows as
we've seen with the solar panels the
cost of output drops dramatically
so the first phase is not about the most
efficient aircraft it's not about the
aircraft that will deliver the lowest
nox emissions it's about demonstrating
that we can carry hydrogen safely on
board we can burn it safely on board and
can be used to fly passenger aircraft
the key thing is that we don't try to
put everything in the first generation
or we're just going to delay the entry
into service so to try and keep it as
simple as possible
if there are some questions on the
margin they're all in the sort of
business model and market adoption realm
it is very hard to create a
um
technological argument or impossible to
create a technological argument that
says well it's not it's not going to
work right it is going to work
[Music]
you